liebe frau jolie liebe frau werber
herzlich willkommen bei bild schön dass
sie sich die zeit für uns nehmen vor
berbalk sie haben herrn klitschko gerade
gehört erfordert den abbruch sämtlicher
geschäfts beziehungen zu russland
einiges ist abgebrochen aber die
erdölimporte laufen weiter nun gerade in
den minuten vor diesem interview haben
die vereinigten staaten von amerika
bekannt gegeben dass auch sie die
erdölimporte von russland einstellen
werden kanada hat das mit einer sehr
geringen menge bereits getan wann zieht
deutschland nach erstmals schönen guten
abend in dieser bedrückenden zeit und
die worte zerreißen einen natürlich das
herz erst recht die bilder die man ja
minütlich sieht aus kiew aus dem umfeld
von kiew aber erst rechte von der
ostukrainischen seite her und wir
versuchen alles zu tun um diesen krieg
zu stoppen wir müssen aber auch sehr
deutlich sagen dass dieser präsident
derzeit offenbar nicht zu stoppen ist
weil er jegliche menschliche grenzen
überschreitet wir haben gemeinsam nicht
nur mit unseren freunden in kanada
sondern mit den amerikanern als europäer
drei sanktionspaket auf den weg gebracht
die wirkung zeigen das sieht man der
rubel ist massiv abgestürzt aber auf
ihre frage hin mit blick auf
energieimporte das ist ja öl gas und
auch kohle gegen die amerikaner jetzt im
schritt öl zu bannen für uns stellt sich
immer die frage wenn die sanktionen
ergreifen wie lange können wir das
durchhalten und die situation in den usa
und in kanada ist eine andere wir
produzieren selber in deutschland und
auch in europa nicht wirklich viel öl
dass es in kanada und den usa eine
andere das heißt ein drittel unserer
ölimporte kommt aus russland wenn wir
die sofort einstellen würden dann werden
wir in den nächsten tagen uns in
deutschland nicht mehr fortbewegen
können und deswegen müssen wir bei den
sanktionen immer schauen können wir sie
umsetzen und folgen können wir sie auf
dauer umsetzen es bringt nichts jetzt
ein ölimport ben zu verhängen und in
drei wochen halten wir das nicht mehr
durch und müssten das dann zurücknehmen
aber es ist wichtig dass die amerikaner
und die canaria diesen schritt jetzt
gehen also eine sanfte absage weiterhin
von der bundesregierung was die
ölimporte betrifft das wird viele
menschen in der rinehart enttäuschen ich
glaube auch es wird viele deutsche
enttäuschen die ja zu erkennen gegeben
haben in diversen umfragen dass sie sehr
wohl bereit wären mit einer
entsprechenden gesetzgebung die den
benzinpreis unter kontrolle bekommt auch
auf öl zu verzichten wie geht es
überhaupt in der ukraine weiter frau
judy rechnen sie damit dass putin das
land in schutt und asche legen wird so
wie er es in syrien getan hat
natürlich machen wir uns ganz besonders
grosse sorgen darüber was in der ukraine
passiert und das ist natürlich positiv
krieg ein furchtbarer krieg
was ich dem kommentar von frau berbalk
noch hinzufügen würde ist
das ist wirklich ganz besonders wichtig
ist dass der westen in dieser krise
zusammensteht
wir haben zusammengestanden und werden
das auch weiter machen
und deswegen
versuchen die usa und kanada und viele
andere länder europa zu helfen und
deutschland zu helfen
wir wissen dass die realität mit energie
schwieriges und anders ist
deswegen müssen wir sicherstellen dass
der druck auf putin extrem groß
und mir ist auch wichtig zu sagen dass
kanada eine große ukrainische community
hat 15 millionen ukraine und wir werden
schulter an schulter seite an seite mit
ihnen zusammen stehen wie wird diese
hilfe konkret aussehen wir haben über
die drei aktionspakete gesprochen aber
in wahrheit habe ich doch jetzt von
ihnen gehört dass es bei dem bleibt was
im moment geschehen ist und ich habe von
ihnen gehört dass der öl stoppt aus
russland in deutschland nicht kommt und
ich habe von ihren beiden regierungen
auch schon gehört dass die nato niemals
direkt in der ukraine eingreifen wird
heißt das wir müssen dem abschlachten
ukrainischer zivilistinnen und
zivilisten einfach weiterhin zu gucken
frau baerbock naja das schwierige in so
einer situation weil wenn es einfach
wäre dann hätten wir dieses desaster ja
schon gelöst ist dass es nicht schwarz
weiß ist wir sehen ganz klar dass hier
ein mann koste es was es wolle
ein anderes land zerstören will und wir
halten mit allem was wir haben dagegen
aber das heißt nicht dass das was
denkbar ist auch dass verantwortungsvoll
sste ist und wir tragen mélanie julie
für irland ich für mein land wie
gemeinsam für europa und die ganze welt
eine verantwortung für die menschen in
europa in unseren ländern und erst recht
für die menschen in der ukraine und ich
kann das total verstehen dass sie sagen
jetzt müsste man doch aber endlich mal
knallhart auf den tisch hauen aber wie
gesagt wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
putin maximal isoliert wird deutlich
machen dass dieses vorgehen nicht nur
das schlimmste ist was man der ukraine
antun kann sondern auch massive
konsequenzen für sein eigenes land hat
und deswegen sie sagen ja aber sie
wollen das mit dem öl nicht ich würde
sofort importe verbieten wenn ich wüsste
dass es diesen krieg stoppen würde was
ich aber mit einkalkulieren ist muss
sind die folgen die uns selber genauso
hart treffen wenn wir hier in zwei
wochen die situation haben dass
krankenschwester nicht mehr zur arbeit
kommen dass lehrerinnen und lehrer nicht
mehr zur arbeit kommen dass wir wenn wir
mit blick auf gas oder kohle importe
tageweise kein strom haben wie die
situation haben dass nachbarländer wie
polen die jetzt flüchtlinge versorgen
auch kein strom mehr haben auch dann hat
doch putin ein teil gewonnen weil er
weitere länder ins chaos mit rhein
gestürzt hat und in dieser schwierigen
abwägung wie schaffen wir es dieses
furchtbare leiden zu beenden und wie
schaffen wir es gleichzeitig maximal
geflüchtete zu unterstützen treffen wir
entscheidungen die wir treffen und das
was sie gesagt haben es wird keine
sanktionen mehr geben in zukunft nein
das stimmt nicht ich habe hier bereits
vor ein paar tagen gesagt wir bereiten
ein weiteres paket vor aber wie meine
kollegin gesagt hat müssen diese
sanktionen dann nicht nur für
deutschland und die eu greifen sondern
gemeinsam mit kanada und am besten mit
den 141 ländern weltweit die sich gegen
diesen krieg putin gestellt haben weil
es bringt uns nichts wir machen
sanktionen und andere länder sind dann
die orte wo dann der finanzströme die
finanzströme fließen das heißt diese
sanktionen müssen dann auch voll und
ganz weltweit greifen was es auf der
offensiven seite zu erwarten ländern
mittlerweile oder mehrere länder
mittlerweile waffen geliefert ein
streitpunkt nach wie vor kampfflugzeuge
werden kampfflugzeuge aus nato beständen
oder ausländern die mit der natur
verbunden sind in die ukraine geliefert
werden
wir haben auf jeden fall sichergestellt
dass wir die waffen verfügen stellen wir
sind eines der ersten länder das gemacht
hat und wir sind froh dass deutschland
sich hier angeschlossen hat und dass
auch deutschland das historische
statement unterschrieben hat die
außenpolitik ganz grundsätzlich zu
verändern dies ist in nordamerika und
kanada sehr gut angekommen
wir müssen
auf jeder art diplomatisch
wirtschaftlich in jeder einzelnen arzt
sah es in der un
frau bog eine sehr gute rede gehalten
hat oder
im rat für menschen
oder im praktischen rat für uns kanadier
natürlich sehr wichtig ist in jedem
einzelnen gremium an jedem ort müssen
wir uns manipulieren was letzte woche
geschehen ist war
140 länder haben sie zusammen
geschlossen gegen russland und das wird
ein eindruck hinterlassen und leben
retten und über die internationalen
organisationen werden wir auch gleich
noch sprechen frau jolie aber ganz
konkret ich möchte diese frage doch mal
stellen kann die ukraine kampfflugzeuge
erwarten ja oder nein frau bernburg
diese frage gestellt wird sondern wir
haben in den vergangenen dreizehn tagen
mit unseren partnern gemeinsam in der
nato wir saßen am freitag gerade
zusammen beim nato rat darüber
gesprochen wie können wir auch
militärisch weiter unterstützen auch da
schauen wir uns genau an was wirkt am
meisten wir wissen jetzt aus den analyse
bildern das vor allen dingen mit blick
auf raketen die flugzeuge auch vom
himmel holen können dass das wirkt wir
haben bereits was geliefert andere
partner liefern auch mit blick auf die
flugzeug auch darf ich verstehe das ist
das klingt dann so einfach jetzt schickt
sie einfach dahin die situation ist so
die flugzeuge müssen ja auch geflogen
werden können das heißt es können
überhaupt nur sowjetische flugzeuge
geliefert werden es gibt noch zwei
europäische länder die die überhaupt
haben wenn sie welche liefern haben sie
selber keine flugzeuge mehr plus und das
ist mir extrem wichtig das habe ich ja
auch schon anderen fernsehsendungen
gesagt ich finde absolut notwendig in so
einer kriegssituation wo menschen bei
uns wahnsinnige angst haben volle
transparenz walten zu lassen und wir
erleben eine situation dass dieser
präsident jegliche rote linien
überschritten hat ein land überfallen
menschen zivilisten kinder alte menschen
bombardieren und jetzt droht auch mit
blick auf das nato gebiet zu sagen na ja
wir gucken mal was dort passiert und in
so einer situation haben wir als
europäer die verantwortung für 450
millionen europäerinnen und europäer
wobei die ukraine auch zu europa gehört
sicher zu stellen dass dieser krieg
nicht auf nato gebiet sich ausweitet und
deswegen ist es auch mit den
waffenlieferungen so dass wir keine
steilvorlage dafür geben können dass
gesagt wird wir beteiligen uns aktiv an
dem krieg sondern deswegen für öffnen
wirklichen wir auch nicht über welche
kanäle waffen geliefert werden soll dann
machen das so dass wir die ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer erst möglich unterstützen
ohne selber kriegsteilnehmer zu werden
wenn ich nur die worte von witali
klitschko gerade gehört habe und auch
wiederholt vom ukrainischen botschafter
in deutschland dann bleiben dort
natürlich zweifel dass sie bestmöglich
unterstützt werden gleichwohl frau
bernburg sie reden sie reden von dem
russischen präsidenten den wir bei bild
nur noch diktator nennen oder tyrann als
einer menschen der alle roten linien
überschritten hat wie groß ist die
gefahr eines nuklearen konflikt das
haben wir sehr deutlich gemacht mit
solchen worten darf man gar nicht
spielen und das habe ich auch gegenüber
dem russischen präsidenten den mann nun
bezeichnen kann wie man will ich habe
auch deutlich gemacht hat uns eiskalt
angelogen dass das spiel mit dem feuer 1
ist dass man niemals spielen darf mit
blick auf die nukleare frage ist es ja
so diese waffen strahlen auch zurück und
die ukraine ist direktes nachbarland von
russland wir arbeiten gerade mit
hochdruck daran weil wir auch noch
atomkraftwerke in der region haben dazu
eine vereinbarung zu finden
über die in nationale atombehörde
sicherzustellen dass diese
atomkraftwerke nicht beschossen werden
das ist dort nicht noch zu einem
desaster kommt das heißt auf allen
kanälen sind wir unterwegs weil die
situation einfach so ist das wir erleben
müssen das tagtägliche schlimmeres
passiert auf der anderen seite
vielleicht darf ich das auch mal in
dieser sendung sagen danke all die
menschen die jetzt so wahnsinnig
unterstützen was ich hier in berlin sehe
aber erst recht in polen in moldau ein
ganz ganz kleines land da sind menschen
die haben selber ganz wenig fahren
selber mit ihrem auto hinnehmen
geflüchtete auf ihr leben das hier auch
mitten in berlin und wir haben uns heute
auch getroffen um uns gemeinsam darauf
zu verständigen können wir zwischen
kanada und deutschland die
zusammenarbeit verstärken dass wir
flüchtlinge jetzt wirklich weltweit
verteilen kanada hatte melanie solier
angesprochen hat viele menschen aus der
ukraine auch da sind verwandtschaft
beziehung und wir müssen jetzt gerade
länder wie moldau die ein ganz ganz
kleines land sind im prinzip so groß wie
unsere bundeshauptstadt und einen großen
teil von flüchtlingen schon aufgenommen
hat wie können wir die bestmöglich
unterstützt frau jolie sie sprachen
gerade über die vereinten nationen und
überhaupt über die vielen
zwischenstaatlichen lösungen die sie
suchen das klingt sehr gut aber heute
kam die nachricht von den vereinten
nationen dass es den mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern dort untersagt ist die
worte krieg und invasion zu verwenden
wenn sie über den krieg in der ukraine
und die invasion von russischer seite in
der ukraine sprechen wir kennen auch die
rolle von russland in diesen gremien
es sind die überhaupt noch nützlich das
ist doch exakt putins propaganda die
hier in den transnationalen
organisationen verwendet wird
public
key baganda geschieht genau jetzt
während wir hier sprechen nicht nur auf
frösche today oder sputnik überall im
netz auch überall passiert ist und wie
air canada haben hier eine
führungsposition eingenommen darin gegen
eine desinformationskampagne zu kämpfen
und müssen aber immer noch mehr tun
social media für müssen immer noch mehr
tun
wir müssen dieses problem ganz klar an
erkennen und bekämpfen
ja wir müssen zugeben die russen werden
davon beeinflusst und alle anderen
demokratien auch
in allen demokratien haben wir beispiele
von russischer propaganda und
generativen die sich immer
weiterentwickeln und das macht mir
sorgen in jedem krieg
in jedem krieg gibt es auch einen
information denen müssen wir gewinnen
jolie was sagen sie aber noch mal
konkret zu meiner frage dass bei den
vereinten nationen die sie als teil der
konfliktlösung betrachten es den
mitarbeiterinnen untersagt wurde von
krieg und invasion zu sprechen nicht in
den sozialen medien nicht in einem
russischen propagandakanal sondern in
der institution auf die sie ihre
hoffnung setzen ich glaube frau bernburg
auch oder ein teil der hoffnung ebenso
lösung des konfliktes können können wir
uns kann der westen sich das gefallen
lassen
jetzt steht seine jahre als schockierend
absolut nicht zu akzeptieren wirklich
ungeheuerlich und ich kann hier noch
viel länger darüber mich ärgern aber ich
bin nicht überrascht
ich war in genf als der russische
außenminister sergej lawrow in genf bei
der versammlung einfach angefangen hat
zu sprechen und wir sind einfach alle
raus gelaufen die sind einfach alle über
100 länder sind einfach aus dem raum
heraus gelaufen und das ist unsere art
profitieren
jedes mal wenn sie in der un ihre
propaganda maschinerie anschmeißen
werden wir produzieren nicht alleine
sondern mit der eu mit deutschland mit
allen ländern die sich anschließen
wollen denn unsere freiheit ist hier
gefragt und
haben diese vereinten nationen es geht
derzeit darum das leben von unschuldigen
menschen in der ukraine zu retten und zu
schützen es geht aber auch um die
europäische sicherheits ordnung und es
geht um unsere vereinten nationen und
das ist auch unsere historische
verantwortung gerade aus einem land
heraus nach dem zweiten weltkrieg nach
dem schlimmsten gräueltaten sich die
menschheit darauf verständigt hat zu
sagen wir schaffen eine institution
geschaffen verträge die ebenso einen
angriffskrieg als völkerrechtswidrig
einstufen wir schützen menschenrechte
weltweit und deswegen auch bei der
wortwahl ich glaube es ist wahnsinnig
wichtig jetzt nicht dass putins narrativ
die erzählung die propaganda auch noch
zu wiederholen zu sagen auch die
vereinten nationen sind ja irgendwie
schwach und hilflos nein diese vereinten
nationen haben gerade diesen
russischen präsidenten klar und deutlich
gesagt du stehst ganz alleine in der
welt für diesen krieg haben außer
russland nur noch de la cruz
syrien eritrea und nordkorea gestimmt
und andere diktaturen haben nur noch
dafür gestimmt und das hat deutlich
gemacht russland ist isoliert und
deswegen ist es mir auch so wichtig dass
wir die vereinten nationen unterstützen
und im übrigen der generalsekretär der
vereinten nationen hat sehr klare und
deutliche worte zu diesem krieg auch
gefunden und auf der anderen seite das
ist halt politik dann ist einfluss von
russland da deswegen sagen wir auch aus
gewissen gremien der internationalen
organisation schließen wir jetzt
russland aus weil eben gewisse dinge
nicht mehr angesprochen werden können
wie sie eigentlich angesprochen werden
ist frau berbalk sie machen sehr klar
dass sie russland isoliert sehen wollen
und haben auch eine beeindruckende liste
an ländern genannt allein ein land fehlt
auf der liste china mein eindruck ist
dass china sehr eng an der seite
russlands steht es wir haben das in den
letzten wochen immer wieder gesehen
gerade kam eine meldung dass die ersten
chinesen bereits ende februar aus der
ukraine offensichtlich mit
herrschaftswissen gesegnet über die
bevorstehende invasion ausgereist sind
die chinesen die chinesische regierung
peking hat russland geholfen jetzt
wirtschaftlich in dem es auf indem sie
aufträge erteilt hat und
chinesische reporterinnen und reporter
sind embedded mit russischen soldaten
direkt vor ort wie sehr können wir
russland trauen oder andersrum gefragt
wie wenig dürfen wir russland trauen gar
nicht wir können dieser russischen
regierung aber ich möchte unterscheiden
zwischen russland und dieser russischen
regierung wir haben hier heute
demonstrationen in berlin gehabt gegen
diesen krieg da waren viele russen und
russen mit auf der straße in russland
selber obwohl die menschen wissen sie
werden verhaftet und das ist ja nicht
als wenn ich in deutschland auf eine
demo geht komme ich nachher zu meinen
kindern zurück sondern da gehen junge
mütter dagegen großmütter auf die straße
um gegen diesen typ putin zu
demonstrieren wissen nicht ob sie
nachher wieder nach hause kommen können
deswegen wir können diesem russischen
präsidenten kein millimeter vertrauen
und vielleicht war die chinesen mit
nochmal berlin erzwingen können wir den
chinesen vertrauen auch da ist die welt
halt nicht noch rosarot und auch in der
vergangenheit nicht nur rosarot gewesen
deswegen sie haben angesprochen ich
hätte ich ihn nicht aufgezählt china hat
nicht mit russland gestimmt sondern
china hat sich enthalten das ist
natürlich auch keine klare haltung aber
es hat deutlich gemacht dass china
zumindest bei dieser frage den
russischen präsidenten nicht voll und
ganz unterstützt es gibt natürlich von
unserer seite auch gespräche und zwar
intensiver mit china um deutlich zu
machen auch ihr müsst euch hier
positionieren weil das ist ein bruch der
internationalen ordnung aber wir haben
ja bereits bei den olympischen spielen
gesehen dass es da einen engen austausch
gibt und eben was sie angedeutet haben
offensichtlich auch vorab information
dass dieser krieg für china eine
blaupause bei der frage wie weit kann
man gehen im verschieben der
internationalen werteordnung bis der
westen auf wacht auf deutsch gucken die
chinesen gerade zu schauen was wir
machen und entscheiden dann ob sie sich
taiwan unter den nagel reißen das sei
für niemanden eine blaupause sein und
deswegen haben wir so geschlossen als
demokratien auf diesen bruch von
internationalen recht reagiert mit
sanktionen und das ist was was putin aus
meiner sicht überhaupt nicht erwartet
hat es wurde immer beschrieben die
europäer seien schwach die
internationale gemeinschaft sei schwach
so eng hat europa noch nie in der
vergangenheit in der jüngeren
vergangenheit zusammengestanden und das
ist auch unsere klare ansage an andere
regionen an andere länder in der welt
wir stehen für dieses internationale
recht ein und das heißt ein stärkerer
nachbar darf nicht sein schwächeren
überfallen und das habe ich vor den
vereinten nationen auch deutschland
deutlich gemacht das geht alle an weil
so gut wie jedes land auf der welt hat
eben einen stärkeren nachbarn und
deswegen muss man sich so deutlich
positionieren und das gilt weltweit
gleichwohl frau berg wir sind doch
schwach ohne auf die russische
propaganda verfallen zu wollen das ist
mir auch klar die wollen wir hier nicht
wiederholen aber wir sind doch schwach
die raketen die deutschland liefern
wollte die
waren verschimmelt die konten von denen
konnte ein drittel gar nicht mehr
eingesetzt werden deutschland hat nicht
mal das militär um die eigenen
landesgrenzen zu verteidigen und anders
als ihr amtsvorgänger heiko maas ist uns
immer versprochen hat nämlich auch
wörtlich das sind die zitate die nun
auch wieder mit recht hervorgeholt
werden ist deutschland eben sehr wohl
abhängig von russischen
rohstoffreserven
wie abhängig sind wir und mal ganz
konkret gefragt hat heiko maas und hat
auch angela merkel eigentlich die
deutsche bevölkerung angelogen und
ich also jetzt müssen wir mal ganz
trennen wir haben hier ganz viele
unterschiedliche facetten dass wir ein
problem haben mit unserer russischen
energieabhängigkeit
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich das mal so offen
sagen darf da gab es ja noch ein paar
mehr leute in diesem land die uns vor
einiger zeit noch erzählt haben dass wir
mit blick auf diese pipeline diese in
ostritz weiblein sie unbedingt brauchen
und auch über erneuerbare energien wurde
in jüngerer vergangenheit noch anders
gesprochen das ist jetzt definitiv nicht
die schuld der grünen sondern wir hätten
ein angela merkel und hat bereits 2014
als damals ja die krim
völkerrechtswidrig eingenommen wurde
hatte europa gesagt wir müssen uns
unabhängiger machen das ist jetzt aber
schnee von gestern
und jetzt ist es ganz klar wir müssen
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
massiv vorantreiben das ist auch
sicherheitspolitik vielleicht noch den
ersten teil ihrer frage weil es ist mir
wirklich wichtig in diesen zeiten wir
haben das noch nie erlebt zum glück
haben wir noch nie einen krieg so dicht
erlebt auf dem balkan hatten wir ihn vor
vor einigen jahrzehnten und hatten
gehofft dass es nie wieder passiert
deswegen das mit den waffenlieferung
also zum einen werden bei kisten
schimmel ist da drin sind ja waffen
nicht schimmel einer holzkiste ist mal
was anderes aber das mal dahin gestellt
ja aber für die ein drittel war ja nicht
einsehbar ist sei nicht nur eine
verträumte nicht wirklich darum bitten
informationen genauestens zu prüfen das
hat sie melanie jolie angesprochen wir
haben wahnsinnig viele fake news aus
ganz ganz unterschiedliche richten
stimmt wir liefern natürlich waffen die
auch funktionieren die werden auch
vorher getestet und dann vielleicht noch
einmal mit blick auf das militärbudget
ja wir haben hier eine 180 grad wendung
gemacht weil wir uns niemals hätten
vorstellen können dass wir über den
einsatz von militär überhaupt in unserem
gemeinsamen europa widersprechen müssen
aber wenn die welt sich ändert wenn sich
die realität ändert dann muss sich auch
politik ändern aber ich glaube es bringt
überhaupt nichts jetzt zu schauen wer
war in der vergangenheit schuld sondern
jetzt müssen wir gemeinsam auf die
zukunft schauen und da ist mir wichtig
die stärke ist das gemeinsame europa
deswegen gucken wir auch nicht nur auf
den nationalen verteidigungshaushalt
sondern wir als europäer insgesamt
müssen für unsere gemeinsame sicherheit
gemeinsam mit unseren transatlantischen
freundin noch stärker in zukunft dieses
absichten frau jolie in diesem
zusammenhang zwei fragen an sie irland
hat sehr viel schneller und meines
erachtens nach auch effizienter waffen
geliefert als deutschland auch
wesentlich mehr sind sie enttäuscht vom
deutschen bündnispartner dass es eben
doch eine weile gedauert hat bis
deutschland wie wir sagen aus dem quark
und zweitens sind die andere richtung
gefragt auch irland tut sich seit jahren
schwer damit die zwei prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung in die verteidigung
zu investieren wie es die
nato-mitgliedschaft eigentlich vorsieht
sind die änderungen bei ihnen geplant
wie stehen sie dazu
am beginn dieser krise hätte niemand
geglaubt dass deutschland jemals nord
stream zwei kerzen würde und wir sind
das wirklich zu schätzen
aber wir dachten dass wir selbst
sanktionen und die menschen die um ihn
herum sind aber
man habe auch nie die vorstellung
überhaupt dass man die russischen banken
niveau sanktionieren könnte mit 12 das
ist dennoch passiert in den letzten
dreizehn tagen und wir sind wild hier
weiter zu gehen immer weiter das werden
wir tun natürlich muss man aber auch
sagen
ja die sie gesagt haben kanadas hat
viele waffen geliefert wir haben
ukrainische soldaten trainiert und tun
das auch schon seit jahren 30.000 von
ihnen haben wir bereits vor dieser
kriege ausgebildet
und wir glauben dass alle länder sich
hier einschalten sollen und zum glück
sehen wir das auch
der westen rück zusammen wenn sie das
budget ansprechend genau wie deutschland
sehen wir natürlich was hier passiert
und ja das budget war bisher nicht hoch
genug das stimmt der premierminister
wurde das gestern auch gefragt als er in
england war
und er sagte auch ja natürlich sehen wir
die situation und beachten dass wir
wissen wir müssen uns ändern willst
optieren
kanada ist vielleicht nicht auf den
ersten blick eine nachbarstadt von
russland aber wir sind ja schon denn die
sind ja auch ein arktisches land und
wenn man das jetzt mal militärisch sagt
ist es auch wichtig dass wir unsere
souveränität und unsere unabhängigkeit
und unser land schützen
vorwerk frau jolie hat gerade mit rechte
auf die ausbildungsmission der kanadier
in der ukraine hingewiesen ganz anderes
deutschland noch drei tage vor der
russischen invasion lehnte die eu eine
lange angefragte militärische
ausbildungsmission in der ukraine ab
maßgeblich wegen deutschland
gleichzeitig ein etwas anderer fall aber
zahlt auf die gleiche frage 1 blieb der
deutsche chef unseres
auslandsgeheimdienstes in der ukraine
stecken kam tagelang nicht raus als die
krise losbrach wie sehr haben wir
eigentlich verschlafen was es sich dort
für einen sturm zusammenbraut wenn man
die entscheidung deutschlands
unmittelbar davor sei es auf kleiner
ebene mit dem bnd chef sei es auf große
ebene mit den ausbildungsmission
anschaut
in dieser situation
haben wir nichts verschlafen wir haben
in den jahren davor und auch in den
wochen davor nicht geglaubt manche in
manchen bereichen wie gesagt noch zwei
hatte ich schon immer eine sehr klare
haltung zu aber dass der russische
präsident mit allem bericht was uns
eigentlich in der zusammenarbeit
auszeichnet und sich so auch gegen sein
eigenes volk gestellt weil das schadet
seinem eigenen volk ja massiv und in dem
moment wo wir erleben mussten das habe
ich ja bereits gesagt wo wir leben
mussten dass wir belogen worden sind
dass unsere versuche bis zuletzt diesen
krieg diplomatisch zu verhindern dass
diese versuche nicht getragen haben und
ich glaube das ist eine stärke in
solchen momenten zu sagen jetzt ändern
wir unsere eigene politik
und trotzdem bitte auch noch mal hier
ich muss leider jetzt jedes mal
widersprechen weil da wo dinge nicht gut
laufen da stehe ich da und sagt ist
nicht gut laufen müssen wir besser
machen aber mit blick auf die
ausbildungsmission auch das stimmt nicht
sondern wir müssen uns immer
vergegenwärtigen wir sind ein
rechtsstaat wir sind eine demokratie
wenn wir maßnahmen ergreifen dann machen
wir auf der grundlage unseres rechtes
weil wir verteidigen hier gerade unseren
rechtsstaat gegenüber diesen russischen
agieren und das heißt wenn wir
sanktionen ergreifen als europäische
union dann brauchen wir zum beispiel
manchmal ein bisschen länger weil nach
unserer rechtslage so ist das bei jeder
einzelnen person wir begründen müssen
warum wir sie sanktionieren damit dass
dann auch bestand hat vor dem
europäischen gerichtshof das gleiche
gilt für trainingsmission eine
trainingsmission macht am meisten sinn
wenn alle 27 staaten sie gemeinsam
machen wir haben uns genau angeschaut
wie schnell können wir die
trainingsmission auf den weg bringen
hätten wir das über den militärischen
zweit der eu gemacht hätte dass einige
zeit gedauert wir haben das über die
european facility gemacht damit es
schneller geht und klargemacht wir über
fenstern dann kam dieser angriffskrieg
dazwischen deswegen ist das training
können wir jetzt nicht mehr fortführen
die das geplant haben ich bitte hier
wirklich um absolute genauigkeit weil
das ist wichtig ein teil dieser
strategie wir sind im jahr 2022 wird
krieg nicht nur mit waffen und panzern
geführt sondern über das internet und
mit erzählungen mit spins und ein teil
dieser strategie ist den besten zu
spalten ein keil zwischen uns beide hier
zu treiben ein keil zwischen die
europäer zu treiben wo wir auch mal
diskussion hatten aber ungarn und
deutschland polen und deutschland kanada
und deutschland stehen so eng zusammen
wie nie zuvor weil wir deutlich machen
bei solchen fragen gibt es kein
millimeter platz zwischen uns als
demokratie vor berbig teile
vollumfänglich was sie sagen und auch
wir bei bild sind immer wieder mit den
russischen fake news konfrontiert die
sich natürlich über die sozialen medien
versuchen in die redaktion zu schleifen
oder zu schleichen gleichwohl werden sie
mir gestatten dass sich sehr kritisch
nachfrage denn das bleibt der job des
journalismus in ein alter in dem ich
glücklich gefeiert auch gestärkt wird
und seinen job völlig nachkommt ich
würde jetzt gerne noch eine konkrete
frage
auf deutschland stellen und noch eine
kleine runde danach mit ihnen beiden
über die internationalen themen drehen
zwei drei fragen und dann kommen wir zum
ende sie sagten nämlich die erneuerbaren
energie natürlich schon lange ein faible
auch ihrer partei etwas so für sie seit
langem kämpfen das ist der weg jetzt
raus auch aus der abhängigkeit aber sind
wir doch mal ehrlich so schnell wird es
doch nicht gehen wir müssten doch
wahnsinnig viele windräder bauen und wir
sehen ja bereits jetzt die strompreise
in deutschland
absolut
überteuert für viele menschen hier
überhaupt nicht mehr zu bezahlen jetzt
der spritpreis auch noch müssten wir
nicht einfach die drei kraftwerke die
wir am 31 12 21 abgeschaltet haben
wieder einschalten und vor allem die
drei kraftwerke die in deutschland auch
laufen atomkraftwerke dauerhaft
verlängern nachdem wir ja auch sehen
dass die desaster der
atomkraftwerks zeit sehr weit
zurückliegen und es sich eigentlich
mittlerweile meine verhältnismäßig
sichere technologie handelt die
keinerlei co2 ausstoß produziert und
auch keine abhängigkeit zum russischen
tyrannen gute frage und natürlich haben
wir uns auch darüber den kopf zerbrochen
das hat ja mein kollege robert habeck in
den letzten tagen auch deutlich gemacht
die erneuerbaren die werden uns
mittelfristig helfen damit wenn ich in
zehn jahren wieder dastehen und sagen
leider importieren wir 50 prozent der
steinkohle aus russland oder dann aus
irgendeinem anderen land der welt
deswegen beschleunigen wir den ausbau
der erneuerbaren massiv zugleich hilft
uns das aber nicht für jetzt und auch
nicht für den nächsten winter deswegen
kaufte robert habeck überall in der welt
und danke auch an kanada und an andere
länder mit blick auf vor allen dingen
gas gas überall auf der welt ein lng
terminals wird jetzt auf den weg
gebracht sie haben jetzt angesprochen
die strompreise macht den bogen zum
beginn unserer frage genau darüber
müssen wir uns gedanken machen deswegen
können wir auch nicht einfach sagen
morgen sie haben es angesprochen die
erneuerbaren sind noch nicht 100 prozent
stoppen wir alle fossilen importe
sondern wir kaufen jetzt überall auf der
welt ein damit wir unsere energie
abhängigkeit reduzieren können und
schrittweise dann auch wie andere länder
die importe aus russland reduzieren zur
atomfrage auch das haben wir uns
angeschaut und auch hier muss man genau
abwägen die situation ist und deswegen
kann ich die antwort vorweg nehmen es
ist keine option die atomkraftwerke
länger laufen zu lassen ich möchte aber
gerne erklären weil in dieser situation
schauen wir uns schaut sich die
bundesregierung alles an zum einen ist
es so dass die verträge auslaufen die
betreiber sagen selber
sicherheitsgarantien aber auch die
uranvorräte das ist alles nicht mehr auf
halde weil sie sollen ja zum ende des
jahres auslaufen das heißt für den
nächsten winter würde uns das gar nichts
bringen zweiter punkt wir reden über
ölimport bands uran wird auch importiert
auch aus russland viele länder die
atomkraftwerke haben importieren uran
aus russland das heißt bei der ganzen
import frage würde uns das überhaupt
nicht helfen zumal es nicht umsetzbar
ist und dann der dritte punkt sicherheit
wir haben die sicherheitskriterien so
gefasst für die laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke und nicht für die zukunft
und ich glaube gerade dieser krieg zeigt
uns noch mal warum es so richtig war in
deutschland aus atomkraft auszusteigen
wir hatten als wir den terrorismus
hatten atomkraftwerke europaweit geprüft
was passiert eigentlich wenn wir einen
terrorangriff auf atomkraftwerk haben
feststellung die meisten sind dafür
nicht gewappnet dann hatten wir das
erdbeben haben sie angesprochen liegt
schon ein bisschen zurück jetzt erleben
wir mitten in einem krieg ist eines der
gefährlichsten ziele ein atomkraftwerk
wenn das angegriffen wird haben wir ein
riesengroßes nuklear desaster das heißt
unabhängig von der fossilen frage zeigt
sich für mich dass wir den weg den wir
als deutsche ja mit einer fiesen großen
mehrheit in der gesellschaft gewählt
haben auch sicherheitspolitisch der
absolut richtig bauwerke glauben sie mir
da mal zu haben zu beginn des interviews
haben sie sehr deutlich gemacht dass sie
den deutschen es nicht zumuten wollen
die energie importe aus russland jetzt
vollständig oder überhaupt zu stoppen
weil sie eben sagten sie sind auch für
das deutsche volk oder primär mal für
das deutsche volk gewählt und da gibt es
eine fürsorgepflicht wenn ich das so
zusammenfassen darf jetzt sagen sie aber
gleichzeitig andersrum kkws weiterlaufen
zu lassen das könne man nun allerdings
auch nicht machen denn ein akw sei im
grunde etwas gefährliches wie können sie
das vor den jetzt sterbenden
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer rechtfertigen
wo sie es in verbindung bringen mit die
deutschen können nicht so hohe
benzinpreise können nicht so hohe
energiekosten haben wenn sie aber
gleichzeitig sagen zum runter dem die
kosten und zum beheben des problems
setzen wir aber nicht mal atomkraftwerke
ein denn da gibt es potenzielle gefahren
terrorangriff erdbeben usw sie haben es
gerade aufgeführt ist da nicht eine
enorme schieflage drin weil ich hatte ja
drei andere argumente erstens technisch
funktioniert das nicht das hat sich
robert habeck hier angeschaut weil die
kraftwerke zum ende des jahres auslaufen
ohne brennstäbe können wir auch
atomkraftwerke nicht weiter betreiben
das hatte ich ja gerade gesagt wir
müssten uran importieren unter anderem
aus russland also wäre das das gleiche
wie beim öl zweiter punkt wir haben
keine sicherheits standards mehr wir
können schlecht atomkraftwerke laufen
lassen wenn sie nicht
sicherheitsüberprüft sind könnte man
sagen müssen wir alles schneller machen
aber auch das liegt mit der dritte punkt
der ist aber der entscheidende punkt wir
können so schnell für den winter mit
blick auf das die eigentlich zur
abschaltung sind und das sagen ja die
betreiber selber für den winter würde
uns das kein gewinn bringen alles würde
ein zwei jahre dauern bis wir uran dann
aus russland neu importiert haben die
sicherheitsvorkehrung getroffen haben
das heißt für die kritische phase dem
nächsten winter den nächsten herbst
müssen wir jetzt öl und gas massiv dazu
kaufen aus anderen regionen der welt und
kohle damit wir dann über den winter
kommen können und glauben sie mir ich
sehe jedes einzelne schicksal wenn wir
ein hebel hätten diesen krieg zu stoppen
mit wirtschaftlichen kosten ohnegleichen
bei uns wir würden ihn ergreifen nur
dieser präsident hat sich in den kopf
gesetzt er bricht alle regeln die wir
ihnen im weg stellen und deswegen ist
wie auf so unterschiedlichen kanälen
aktiv sein
noch eine frage an sie frau julie bevor
ich ihnen beide unsere abschlussfrage
kurz stellen werde sie haben deutlich
gemacht wie wichtig die internationalen
organisationen sind und ihre regierung
hat selbst ein verfahren gegen wladimir
putin vor dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof auf den weg gebracht
sollten da nun ermittlungen aufgenommen
werden wird kanada dann tatsächlich
versuchen putin zu verhaften und nach
den haag zu bringen
[Musik]
ernsthaft wir müssen natürlich
sicherstellen
wir haben den internationalen regional
gerichtshof gewandt wir haben klar
gemacht dass russland ein aggressor ist
und sichergestellt dass die vor gericht
kommen für kriegsverbrechen und
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
aber um einmal auf ihren ihr argument
von der vorzug zu kommen hier sind
einige fragen die beantwortet werden
ich konnte nach polen gehen und auch
nach rumänien haben nicht ganz rückkehr
gekommen und überall wo ich war in den
flugzeugen flughäfen den bahnhöfen habe
ich überall flüchtlinge getroffen
diese krise ist schlimm furchtbar und
deswegen haben wir in kanada beschlossen
kein limit auf die anzahl der
flüchtlinge zu legen die wir willkommen
heißen werden wir arbeiten mit polen und
deutschland zusammen in diesem prozess
wir wissen dass sie aus hilfe brauchen
und wir sind hier um ihnen zu helfen wir
werden sie alle aufnehmen wenn es sein
muss
wir wissen auch dass die energiekosten
und die gaspreise hoch gegangen sind in
ihrem land in meinem sind
und wir wissen dass die kooperation
gemeinsam statt um für die freiheit
kämpfen und die länder jetzt leiden zu
schützen und das ist der grund warum wir
weiterhin mit deutschland
zusammenarbeiten werden ihre fragen
haben sehr relevant sie sind wichtig
aber lassen sie uns das ziel im auge
behalten so viel druck wie es geht auf
das russische regime und außenministerin
jolie hat gerade noch mal angesprochen
wie wichtig es ist dass man jetzt auch
auf einem sehr persönlichen level
zusammen steht deswegen erlauben sie mir
beide meine abschlussfrage vielleicht
zuerst an den gast in unserem land auch
persönlich kann jetzt jede und jeder
einiges tun weniger heizen es ist banal
weniger auto fahren sie beide haben ganz
besondere aufgaben und arbeiten ohnehin
sehr viel man könnte auch flüchtlinge
aufnehmen was leisten sie nehmen sie
jemanden auf
einem orientalisch bin dazu gefühlt ich
will helfen kanada hat 60.000 syrische
flüchtlinge aufgenommen damals während
riesig weiß deutschland hat natürlich
noch mehr aber wir haben sie mit
flugzeugen eingeflogen nach kanada
ich komme von einem teil meines landes
und repräsentiere menschen in meinem
land die so viele syrer sind
und diese syrer sind hier seit fünf
sechs sieben jahren da sie wählen mich
und darauf bin ich stolz und deswegen
sage ich ganz klar wie auch annalena
baerbock hier gesagt hat wir sind alle
emotional extrem investiert in diese
krise
wir haben beide vor drei monaten erst
unser amt angenommen und das war eine
feuertaufe
aber wir werden sicherstellen dass wir
die führungsaufgabe auch schaffen das
ist das was die menschen jetzt brauchen
führung
wir werden diesen kampf kämpfen gegen
die verrückt vielen dank und frau
werbung vielleicht können sie uns noch
kurz ganz persönlich wissen lassen für
die leserinnen und lesern zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer von bild tv was tun sie
ganz persönlich plant sie flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen
haben sie die heizung abgedreht was
welche maßnahmen treffen sie auf dieser
privaten ebene
kritische fragen findet er gut
persönliche fragen finde ich auch gut
aber heizung abdrehen ist ein guter
punkt aber auch dass wir diesen krieg
nicht stoppen deswegen finde ich muss
man jetzt hier wahnsinnig aufpassen dass
man nicht das gefühl vermittelt jeder
dreht jetzt mal die heizung ab oder
unterstützt flüchtlinge und dann ist
alles gut das ist ja das schlimme an
krieg es ist nicht einfach so alles gut
sondern wir müssen auf allen kanälen
alles versuchen aber auf ihre frage zu
antworten
auch mit blick auf den syrien krieg habe
ich eine patenschaft übernommen und auch
diese frage schaue ich mir genau an aber
auch hier müssen wir nicht so einfach
dinge daher sagen ja wir leben gerade
das vor allen dingen frauen mit kleinen
kindern kommen schulkindern
kindergartenkindern wir haben am anfang
geschaut wir liefern nahrungsmittel
wasser aber was wir jetzt vor allen
dingen brauchen ist psychologische hilfe
weil hier kommen frauen mit kleinkindern
die gerade ihren vätern und ehemännern
sagen mussten auf wiedersehen wir wissen
nicht wann wir dich wiedersehen das
heißt gerade auch wenn man jetzt
menschen aufnimmt muss man sich genau
anschauen was ist das einen
kindergartenplatz schulplatz und
deswegen es tut mir leid aber
unterstreichen wir hier diesen appell
auch noch mal weltweit wir werden die
flüchtlinge haben deutschland tut alles
individuell schaut glaube ich jeder wie
er gerade unterstützen kann auch ich
auch meine familie aber was wir vor
allem brauchen ist ein kollektiven
weltweiten kraftakt weil all diese
kinder müssen zur schule gehen müssen in
den kindergarten gehen und das ist das
woran wir gerade arbeiten jedes einzelne
land ab zu telefonieren wie können wir
jetzt den geflüchteten die das glück
hatten zu fliehen ein ein bisschen
frieden und ein bisschen sicherheit
geben ministerin jolie und ministerin
werburg ich danke ihnen für ihren besuch
bei bild tv danke